hi everyone welcome to the last lecture
of cs330
um today it's a very exciting lecture
we'll be talking about Frontiers and
open challenges in multitask and metal
learning and we will have um eight
um speakers who'll tell us about some of
the some of the work that is at the
frontier of uh of multitask meta
learning and uh and actually other
subfields as well so it should be really
exciting it will give you the
opportunity not only to learn about
their work but also to actually meet the
people who who are behind it
uh before we get started a few Logistics
um so again this is the last lecture
today
um on we will have the instructor office
hours right after this which will be
also held on zoom and the link to join
that is on canvas
uh and then on Tuesday we'll have the
project poster session and then
Wednesday the projects are viewed
um
one more thing is that we'll have the
final course survey
um at some point I'm not exactly sure
when you will get an email about this
but you will and we really appreciate
your feedback that really helps us
improve the course and we incorporated a
lot of the feedback from previous years
to make the course better so please take
the time to fill those out these are
really really helpful and we really
appreciate your feedback
thank you
all right so today we'll be talking
about Frontiers and open challenges and
I split them into two big topics
one will be about utilizing zero zero
shot generalization of large language
models and we talked quite a bit about
large language models we had one of the
lectures on it one of the guest lectures
from Poland
and we'll explore some of the questions
when it comes to using these large
language models we'll talk about how to
fine-tune these large models without
um negative transfer
and we'll also talk about how we can
apply these large language models to
other domains such as robotics for
instance
and then in the second part of the
lecture we'll talk about how we can make
reinforcement learning a better data
sponge
and this might be a little enigmatic at
this point I will explain what I mean by
this when we get there but some of the
topics that we'll discuss will include
how to scale up data collection to allow
how to have robots to collect a lot of a
lot more data that they're collecting
currently
and how we can utilize broad offline
data sources including non-robotic data
sources and then how we can apply
reinforcement learning for lifelong
settings as well
and then at the end we'll also discuss
open challenges
all right so let's start with utilizing
zero shot generalization of large
language models
um so just a few words of introduction
well what is special about large
language posters so a lot of hyper
random and uh maybe they hide this a
little bit too much but the one thing
that is extremely exciting about them is
their is their ability to do perform
zero shot generalization
um and Colin and his lecture talked a
little bit about how they could be
viewed as the as models that do
implicitly meta learning but their zero
stretch generalization is something that
uh we really haven't seen at that scale
um and that makes them extremely
exciting and extremely useful for other
domains as well
um
so with that
um I would like to welcome Eric Mitchell
who will tell us a little bit about how
we can find you in these large bounds
what are the difficulties that come with
that
and how we can do this better without
um having any negative transfer so Eric
Mitchell is a PhD student with uh Chris
Manning and Chelsea Finn
um so Eric please take it away
yeah thanks for the lovely intro Carol
uh great to great to be here and talk
for just a couple minutes about our work
um maybe if you could uh stop sharing
your screen I can
show uh
slides perfect thank you
so as Carol mentioned I'm gonna say a
couple words about uh fine-tuning on on
basically one example without negative
transfer which we can sort of think
about as as editing a pre-trained neural
network
so I'll get right into it basically what
it what do I mean by editing a neural
network and why do we want to do this
well you're probably familiar with the
fact that when we train or all Network
on some big data set like imagenet or
Wiki text
um they end up sort of soaking up a lot
of the knowledge one way or another in
these data sets but obviously as Sam
Altman pointed out in his tweet
um even a big model like gbt3 is still
wrong and and even when they're correct
at the moment that training you know
completes uh over time their predictions
may become obsolete so
um as an example if we take some you
know more or less state-of-the-art
question answering model
um like like T5 and we ask it who's the
Prime Minister the UK is it's going to
say Theresa May and
um depending on how familiar you are
with UK politics you know you'll know
that this is not the prime minister of
the UK though it used to be and so this
just reflects the fact that this model
was trained on data that was gathered
you know in the past and so ideally what
we'd like to be able to do is locally
tweak our model's behavior on sort of
just one example without you know
destroying its its representations and
its predictions on other parts of the
the input domain
and this problem isn't really specific
to language models although they they
provide sort of a convenient modality to
highlight you know how this failure
occurs we can come up with examples uh
with image classifiers kind of screwing
up when they're you know exposed to one
particular background but you know not
otherwise policies that make mistakes in
one particular configuration of the
environment not others translation
systems you know mistranslating
particular phrases between particular
languages and so on and so forth so it's
a it's a fairly General problem that
that crops up when we sort of start to
deploy these models and then time goes
by
so in other words the model's mostly
right but we want to figure out how to
change it for kind of just this example
and and you know the related examples
so how do we actually do this
um well you know if you squint at it
it's sort of like One-Shot learning in a
way I mean we we get one example and we
get the label for that example and we
want to correctly change our model for
that one example
so in our sort of normal few shot
learning setup we're going to have some
metadata set where here our metadata set
is a data set of individual questions
um and each question is sort of a
different One-Shot learning task so we
have kind of facts edit the input the
question why edit the true label for
that question and then X Prime is sort
of our like query input like a
rephrasing of the question to see if our
you know One-Shot adaptation actually
generalizes
so as an example of this we would have X
edit is like who's the PM of the UK we
would put this through our pre-training
model and we would say well it says
Theresa May instead of Boris Johnson
that's not so good
um and so you know that's sort of our
support example we would give it a
support label essentially which is the
edit Target Boris Johnson and then we
have a query input X Prime which checks
if the model correctly you know has
changed its predictions not just for
that exact input but for related ones
and so this is basically One-Shot
learning
um but this doesn't really fully get at
the editing problem because you know we
have an additional issue here which is
after we've performed this edit we want
to make sure that our model is making
the same predictions on unrelated data
as it did before we made the edit so if
we have this sort of control input X
lock this sort of locality constraint
like who is the president of France you
know if we change the prime minister of
the UK we don't want to change the
president of France and so we want to
have an additional constraint that's not
only saying after adaptation what is my
model doing but it should also be
constraining the difference in the
behavior of the model before and after
adaptation so this is a little different
than normal Fusion learning
and so at this point you might think
well okay we have this sort of slightly
different loss function let's throw a
mammal at it or some other algorithm
um but there's sort of one other
consideration which is that as opposed
to maybe normal meta learning where we
start out with sort of a random model
and then we meta train it so that it's
good at adapting in this setting we're
actually given a pre-trained model up
front and so we don't actually want to
change that model initialization because
the pre-trained model we are assuming
sort of performs well most of the time
so somehow we need to do the metal
learning without changing our
initialization and this you know makes
it difficult to straightforwardly apply
an algorithm like mammal where the
representation power of of meta learning
comes from this really big parameter
space in the model initialization
so instead what we're going to do is we
need the metal learner to be separate
from Theta and so one way or another we
need to parametrize some transform of
the update um which are these you know
one way or another these little networks
that basically take the fine-tuning
gradient and map it to a new sort of
pseudo gradient which provides the
properties that we want for edits and so
this is sort of uh the framework that
I've been thinking about we've been
thinking about for editing
um and and uh you can you can do some
pretty interesting things that basically
give the behavior that shown in this
diagram here so to recap editing models
lets us locally adjust their behavior
after training which can be useful and
sort of a wide variety of circumstances
and it's sort of like one shot learning
except we have you know these these
couple of different tweaks to the to the
setup um you know including the the
adaptation should only be a local change
and then we also sort of don't really
want to change the initialization during
the course of this meta training so um
hopefully that was uh
presented in a way that was somewhat
parsable if you're interested there's a
paper that we've recently put on archive
called Fast model editing at scale
thank you so much Eric
um are there any questions we have a
little bit of time
um so if there are any questions from
the audience please just speak up or
raise your hand
actually I have one question do you
think that uh changing the or modifying
the gradient itself the way you're doing
it in in this paper could be applied
Beyond you know editing large language
models but could be also a different
form of meta learning in general
yeah for sure I mean there are there are
sort of a handful of different
algorithms like meta curvature or warp
grad or
um you know meta SGD Etc that are
basically
learning some transformation of the
gradient maybe they also you know learn
the initialization but they sort of add
this expressiveness by transforming the
gradient and and yeah I mean this this
seems like it could be pretty directly
applied to these settings and we kind of
came to it motivated by the editing
problem but realized sort of the
solution is actually probably quite a
bit more General than than just a
specific setting so
um yeah
awesome cool
um it's the order any questions from the
audience
you have one
yeah I've seen recently
yeah this is pretty hard fascinating
down the road to the applications
and it's mostly right
um but there's some cases you want to
get um like it's wrong that you want to
fix or maybe it could it be like
um like with the UK prime minister
example that's something that's changing
um constantly and so like more about a
like all this needs to be updated
because of Changing Times
um yeah I'm sorry yeah
yeah sure so I think the immediate
application is is more like what I
presented in terms of you know we we
maybe Google deploys a translation model
and they get like a handful of user
reports every day and ideally you'd have
some sort of pretty quick automated
process to be able to take these user
reports and sort of inject them into the
model quickly so you don't have to
retrain or go through some long process
to fix the model
um and these might be due to just errors
during training or temporal shift
um I think longer term it would be
interesting to sort of start tying this
editing you know Direction into more
like continual learning settings where
we don't want to just sort of do one
edit or a big batch of edits once right
up front but ideally we have some way to
sort of either take a pre-trained model
or tweak a pre-trained model such that
we can sort of successfully successively
patch it in this way and and not sort of
compound this drawdown that's incurred
every time I'm doing edits I would say
longer down the road you sort of want to
tie it with continual learning
thank you
um all right great thank you Eric so
much uh feel free to drop out of the
call I know that you're busy thanks so
much
um
all right so
we talked a little bit about how we can
fine tune or edit these large language
models
uh let's see does this work
um let's talk a little bit about how we
can apply these larifying response to
other domains
um so there is a little bit of work on
applying the large language models to
other domains that still involve
language and there's some interesting
work coming from openai
um that talks about solving math word
problems for instance where I'm given a
math question like this Ali is a dean of
a private school where he teaches one
class John's the dean of a public school
gym has two classes in school each
classes one one eight the capacity
capacity of allies class which has the
capacity of 150 students what is the
combined capacity of both schools it
turns out that they can train the model
uh that is pre-trained on gpt3 that can
actually answer that that question
correctly so
um they take that question put it in a
prompt for a large language model and
then the model is able to Output the
correct answer
um but it turns out that actually just
fine-tuning that model to these kind of
questions doesn't work very well so
instead what they do is they train an
additional model that does verification
so given a set of different answers and
the question that was originally asked
it can
um just discriminatively say which
answer is correct or if there's no
correct answer to say that there's no
correct answer and it turns out that
this model
um is actually provides quite a bit of
boost of of performance and it's much
easier to train them all to verify the
solution than to train them to fine-tune
the model to always propose the correct
solution so then at test time they would
have the large language model produce a
set of different solutions and then use
the verification model to verify which
one is correct and that achieves fairly
High result
they've opened it they've also showed
some applications of large language
models to something like code completion
where you can
um where they introduce this tool called
codex where you can specify the
instruction that you would want the
model to help you with to specify the
code for then that instruction is then
changed to
um to look like a comment so they take
the prompt they put it as the comment
for a python python code that will be
generated that model wasn't fine-tuned
in a lot of python instructions
associated with the comments as well and
then the the large language model
outputs the python code that is being
executed and you see the results of that
and there's obviously many many
applications of that
um as well starting from you know just
helping us be better colors and also
make it very
really interactive tool that would allow
maybe more people getting through coding
um so these are some applications of
large language models that we see today
that still involve a lot of language
itself
um but I thought that one interesting
topic would be to talk about how large
language models can be applied to other
domains that maybe are not necessarily
connected to language such as robotics
um so with that
um next we'll talk about how to apply
large language models to other domains
and I would like to invite Eric Chang
um who is a senior research scientist
working at Google brain and brain
robotics where we work together on a lot
of these problems
um and Eric will talk to us a little bit
about his work on that topic
thanks for the intro Carolyn for
inviting me to give a quick talk on on
this this project at uh that we did at
Google so yeah my name is Eric Jang I'm
a researcher at Google working on robots
so I'll be talking about BCC zero shot
task generalization with robotic
imitation learning here's a list of the
collaborators that The Usual Suspects
and uh you know large-scale robotic
learning
so um you know as a quick preliminary uh
can we can we learn tasks in the real
world with deep learning on robots and
the last few years and you know many
years before that have suggested that
the answer is yes so you can do a single
task learning with pick and place and it
generalizes to a variety of objects you
can do cable insertion and it also
generalizes to different situations
block stacking also generalizes in this
work we also study a little bit of pick
and place as well
um but as I'm sure many of the students
in this class are interested in
um can we kind of get one network or one
policy to learn multiple tasks in the
real world and again the answer is also
yes so some of the work by Carol and and
the collaborators have done this on
empty opt there's some other work with
Transporter Nets and task embedded
control networks all suggesting that you
know unsurprisingly you can get robots
to do multiple things and there's some
sort of generalization uh and knowledge
transfer between there as well
so the goal of this work was to look at
whether robots can learn tasks that they
haven't been trained on in the real
world so not only are we doing multitask
where we want to generalize a test time
to new tasks that it hasn't seen demos
for
the setup is very simple so we collect a
lot of data with expert tally operation
on on a 100 plus manipulation tasks we
use pretty much the simplest learning
algorithm possible for um for you know
learning visual motor control which is
imitation learning so image in action
out we regress this to expert
demonstrations and then at test time we
command it with a new task
um and and it'll just generalize to to
new instructions so in the blue squares
here you see some of the training task
sentences like place the bottom ceramic
Bowl place the bottle and knock the
Eraser over and so forth and then the
green boxes contain test tasks for which
the instructions we've never trained the
policy on
the model architecture is very simple
it's just a modification of a resnet and
the resonant takes in a frozen
pre-trained sentence encoder embedding
or a video encoder embedding I'm just
going to talk about the sentence encoder
aspect of this in stock but you can
think of them as interchangeable
so we have the training tasks divided
into two sets of objects the object set
on the top contains tasks like place the
sponge in the ceramic bowl and the
objects on the bottom which has mostly
different objects has things like wipe
the trades sponge or you know put this
cup in that other cup and so forth so
the cool thing uh about training all
these tasks is that we kind of get
generalization
um you know through the magic of deep
learning which is at a test time you can
mix together objects in these different
object sets and command it with a
natural language instruction that it's
never been trained on before so it's
never seen like the grapes and the
ceramic Bowl in the same same image in
the training data and it hasn't been
trained on the sentence place the grapes
in the ceramic Bowl but it'll still
generalize and do the correct Behavior
here's some other videos of the held out
tasks that I can do
and uh so so what are the takeaways here
well so we've seen that the system which
called BCC generalizes to unseen points
in some pre-trained frozen embed task
embedding space and if you'll permit me
some uh you know wild speculation here I
think that large language models are
much more than a way to provide a policy
with a task so I mean that's what we do
in this this paper but as you can see
from our results language allows you to
compose semantics together like unseen
subject object verb combinations but
beyond that language has a lot more kind
of power than that so there's this idea
of like Chomsky and recursion which is
that you can embed Clauses inside of
other Clauses and you can do this over
and over again you can perform logical
reasoning within language as you've seen
with um with these uh open AI codex
examples and sometimes even like fuzzy
logic is okay so when you write like a
programming doc string you know it's
it's kind of like logical but not really
and still like language models can
understand that so if you believe that
large language models can can do this
then it might be a really nice substrate
for improving generalization
and you know in machine learning we have
this perspective that generalization is
like this notion of invariance so
um
you see different images But ultimately
like the things that you see at test
time even though you haven't seen them
before they kind of mean the same thing
as something you saw at training time
and that's what that's what allows
robots to generalize to new scenes
the linguist view on generalization is
that words are some sort of discrete
unit of meaning and language is about
composing discrete tokens into more
complex meanings so as a recipe for kind
of making more powerful more General
systems maybe what we should do is take
our data like robot episodes or
something
we we pair that with a bunch of Rich
human language for example by just
describing it
and then we train some sort of data
model jointly with a language model and
we use the language aspects of
compositionality and recursion and and
logical reasoning to then now compose
and control the data in any way that the
language permits which is pretty much
everything so I have a I have a blog
post where I talk about this called just
ask for generalization you want to take
a look and I think that's my time so
thank you very much
thank you Eric
um are there any questions
I have a quick question
um super interesting uh work I I'm I'm
curious like what you if you see any
sort of limits in the pre-training
procedures we used for these large
language models and basically like if
you could pre-train that model yourself
or if you could make a little adjustment
to how that model was pre-trained do you
think there are there's a lot of sort of
Headroom still to you know squeeze a lot
more kind of compositionality or
recursion from those models or do you
think the pre-training we do now is
basically like the vast majority of the
benefit we're going to get from these
I don't have a good answer for that Mike
if I had to take a guess uh probably
like some fine tuning would be necessary
um because like you know aligning the
language compositionality and
generalization to like what you actually
want at deployment time
um seems tricky and maybe additional
kind of feedback via fine-tuning and you
know customized data collection would
help
awesome
um do we have any other questions any
participants
um I would actually have one question to
you Eric as well um do you think that um
it's really interesting the perspective
that you said at the end that uh maybe
we could just collect robotic data and
um label it with language and then just
ask for what we want uh do you think
there's an equivalent to there's always
there always exists a language prompts
that you can specify that foot uh the
equivalent to an existing algorithm that
we already have
basically does this mapping always
exists do you think
um
are you saying like is it possible to
get the behavior of any algorithm by
conditioning on language that's right
yeah I would argue yes because language
also supports uh not only does it
support fuzzy logic as we see in codex
but it also supports like concrete logic
you could just you know put in the
tokens of an actual program into the
language string right so if your neural
network learns to do program
interpretation then it could
conceptually do that as well
both very interesting uh right I think
we have one raised hand
oh yeah
and my question relates to Long Horizon
tasks
um
sequences
performance fairies and tasks and if you
have any ideas on overcoming some
additions thought our face stuff like
learning a policy for a long time
sure so uh I'm just gonna kind of focus
on the kind of concrete robotic results
and not any of this kind of speculative
language stuff
um so in general learning longer Horizon
tasks is much harder than learning short
Horizon tasks and we see that there's a
strong negative correlation between the
length of a demo and the Learned
policies success rate
um so we're controlling at 10 Hertz
which is pretty high frequency for
robotic deep learning and as a result
our performance numbers aren't super
good but yeah like they're in the like
100 to 200 number of decisions
um I think this is more of like a how do
you get reliable learning in these kind
of hard mdps
um yeah so it's open problem in the
field
thank you thanks Eric
um next we'll have Corey Lynch
um who is also a senior research
scientist at uh at Google brain where we
work together on some of these things
and uh he will talk to us a little bit
about language conditioning mutation
learning as well but it will be slightly
different and I think there might be
some different conclusions also
um about using large language models so
accordingly please take it away great
thank you Carol hi I'm Corey
um and like Carol said I'll be
presenting some joint work with
colleagues at Google brain on combining
robot learning with large language
models yeah so much like the last talk
the setting that we're interested in is
a single robot that can learn a very
large number of tasks and furthermore
we'd like users to be able to specify
any of these tasks in freeform natural
language
and I also like the last work we're
restricting our attention to just simple
supervised imitation learning
so a typical multitask imitation
learning setup might look like this
where you collect a large number of
demonstration data sets for each for
each task you perform supervised
learning and then at test time you might
condition on things like one hot task
IDs but if you'd like to scale to a very
large number of text commands for
imagine imagine like push the button or
even something like move your hand back
slightly something more interactive you
can imagine that these collection
requirements might actually get quite
expensive and this mode of behavior
conditioning can become pretty
inflexible
so the main questions we asked ourselves
in this work were how can we lower the
collection requirements can we instead
learn a large number of skills
self-supervised from unlabeled data
that's much less expensive to collect
and second if you've learned a lot of
these behaviors how can you actually
condition them with things like freeform
text
and then finally this one's kind of
subtle and specific to text conditioning
language can almost be too flexible
there's so many ways that you can think
of describing the same tasks it's
unlikely that you actually cover them
all in training so how can you solve for
new synonym instructions at test time
without having to collect new robot data
so I'll quickly describe our approach
the first ingredient is a large
unstructured play data set here a human
teleoperates the robot and plays with
the objects in the scene in as many ways
that they can think of so you can see
there's no upfront test definition and
no resets and this is important because
it means humans can quickly collect lots
of demonstration data covering many
tasks and so we see a lot of behaviors
on display here how do you actually
train a robot to execute specific ones
from text descriptions
so say you've collected a number of
hours of play you can now consider all
one to two second random windows and one
thing to note here is that each window
contains the exact information for how
the robot got from an arbitrary start
state to an arbitrary end State and
nothing stops you from treating each of
these as demonstrations for how to reach
goal images with a robot at the same
time we can send less than one percent
of these to crowdsourced annotators and
after watching a video we can ask them
what text instruction would you have
given the robot to get it to go from
start frame to end frame and so in this
way we can efficiently mine two
demonstration data sets from play one
big one solving for image goals and a
smaller one solving for text goals
so say you have these data sets rather
than trained a separate policy on each
we're now instead going to train one big
policy to solve for either image or
language goals and you can also think of
this as just doing language condition
learning with an auxiliary
self-supervised loss to improve sample
efficiency and we found that this this
sort of shared training scheme is
actually fairly important it allows us
to reduce the cost of language
annotation to less than one percent of
the collected robot experience
and so at test time we're only going to
use text conditioning here's an example
of a human typing free
Forum natural language commands to the
agent you can see the robot executing
multiple of these in a row and the
Agents receiving onboard RGB camera
input and free time freeform text
instructions and then producing actions
in closed loop at 30 Hertz so in the
interest of time I'll refer you to more
videos at the link above
um but then so yeah we've now described
a system that can one learn behaviors
from unstructured data and to kind of
allow people to command these with with
natural language what about number three
so in our in our experiments we found it
simple and what we think is a actually
like a fairly generic solution to this
instead of learning on top of raw text
instructions first embed them in the
space of a large language model that's
been pre-trained on web scale Text data
so why do this
pre-trained language models have been
shown to become synonym aware meaning
they can map at the sentence level uh to
disjoint but semantically similar
sentences to the same region of
embedding space
and so by doing robot learning on top of
pre-trained embeddings the language
model is responsible for mapping new
instructions at test time to ones that
the robot has already been trained to
follow and so we think this is a pretty
nice separation of concerns this means
that the policy itself doesn't need to
know how to generalize it's just the
language model that needs to know how to
generalize and so practically this means
that your agent can now follow thousands
of new synonym instructions at test time
in zero shot without requiring new robot
demonstrations which is good because
robot demonstrations are expensive
um and another nice thing is that if
your pre-training process happens to be
multilingual this means that you can
even follow instructions in new
languages that you've never collected so
this is what you see here this is our
Agent following zero shot French even
though it's only been trained in English
and I think this really illustrates the
power of this uh like both me and the
agent have only ever been trained to
follow instructions in English but by
just applying this trick my agent
suddenly knows how to demonstrate
physical knowledge in French um so I
think this sort of trick highlights like
we're really only scratching the surface
of the knowledge that can be transferred
from large language models to robot
learning
um and so I think there's a lot of
exciting ways that we can think of
transferring even more of this knowledge
uh thanks for your time if you'd like to
learn more about this work feel free to
to check out our paper uh or a bit more
videos on the project page at
language.play.github.io thanks
thank you Curry
um are there any questions
I'll have uh one question
um do you have you noticed or I guess
it's it's a little difficult to um to
evaluate this but can you tell whether
you can also um generate new motions
that you haven't seen before by
conditioning and language in different
ways so it's not just necessarily
indexing what it's already seeing but
maybe it can also generalize to
something that that's never seen before
yeah I think given the fact that the um
I think this might be easier to con to
kind of study in a controlled setting
where you didn't have like the
unstructured demonstration data because
it's fairly hard to guarantee that you
haven't seen this motion before but I
think it's a very interesting question
and it's probably worth some study like
uh can you actually by conditioning on
kind of a new region of uh language
space uh get some sort of like
interpolative nice action behavior that
you can prove has never been seen in
training uh maybe hard to study in the
exact setting that we described here but
I definitely think it's worth studying
in like a new setting
awesome thank you
um any other questions from the
participants we have a raised handle
okay all right yeah I guess um my
question is um
most language work nowadays kind of
focusing on imitation learning and not
reinforcement learning directly so I can
kind of get broader than just the play
data and maybe start learning new things
that's not in the play rate as well
oh sorry
but I also I guess you uh I don't know
if you have any distribution shift
issues
if you just uh do a mutation learning
and um yeah unusual issues would be
electronic I guess you can do
reinforcement learning language
yeah I mean I think there's a lot of
really interesting uh reinforcement
learning language plus language work and
I think you might even be hearing about
some really interesting applications of
that right kind of in the the following
uh speakers but the at least for us the
reason that we restricted our attention
to imitation learning was uh to avoid
kind of questions like uh how do you
specify rewards in the real world how do
you do X like meaningful exploration
targeted exploration
um kind of these are like thorny
questions when you when you try to scale
up to Robotics and so at least for us
the question was like how far can we
push simple imitation learning uh kind
of Until It Breaks
um and as for things like distribution
shift uh if you check out the the paper
we actually have some uh some like
interesting results about the the
robustness of uh policies when they're
trained over unstructured data as
opposed to kind of more rigid curated
data sets
um precisely to address these these
things like distribution [ __ ] so just by
training on kind of like more diverse
data you can uh you can you can show
that these policies that test time are a
little bit more uh like a little bit
more robust to perturbation and kind of
distribution trip than if you train them
on kind of more rigid and kind of
curated data sets um but that being said
these it is still imitation learning so
the the uh the the problem is you you
can of course get off of uh you you're
still subject to all of the compounding
error um you don't have like a generic
solution
[Music]
[Music]
trajectory for that language instruction
unless you're I guess if the player is
large enough this won't be an issue but
yeah so if uh the the key thing here is
that we're restricting to short Horizon
behaviors and so certainly for like a
long enough Horizon uh you might do a
kind of a lot of sub-optimal things in
between getting from the start state to
the end State
um but at least by looking at like one
to two second Windows uh empirically
just by like watching a lot of these
videos you can kind of uh convince
yourself that a lot of these are are
like fairly optimal for the short
Horizon
um of like straight line reaching start
state to end State
um and you you also get you also get uh
kind of text instructions paired to
windows that are like uh move your arm
to the left and then move it back so not
necessarily tasks you would ever come in
but more just descriptions of what's
Happening all right thank you
thank you Curry
um and since uh we just there was a
question about using language in
reinforcement learning our next speaker
will talk exactly about this so next we
have uh Suraj Nair who's a PhD student
of Chelsea event well tell us a little
bit about how we can apply large
language models or language in general
in reinforcement learning take it away
great uh thanks Carol so hopefully
everyone can can see my screen I'm Suraj
uh I'm a busy student with Chelsea and
this is some work we did uh in our lab
and with some uh collaborators at Google
as well
um called learning language condition
robot behavior from offline data and
crowdsourced annotation and the broader
goal in this work is kind of similar the
the few prior uh presentations as well
as we want to learn you know have our
robots be able to learn from large uh
offline data sets to be able to many
different uh Downstream tasks uh and
particularly we'd like to be able to
learn from a kind of non-expert offline
offline data and in this paradigm
humans need sort of easy and effective
ways of actually specifying these tasks
and the rewards and success criteria
um and so you know one common approach
that's used is goal images right so you
could have an image that specifies the
test and many priorities have done this
and it's it's a natural choice because
this these goal images exist in the data
set already but there's a number of
drawbacks like Human Action needs to go
and I test time and create this goal
image to specify the task and it can
often over specify the tasks like
different different objects that are not
task relevant I can't specify persistent
Behavior so in this work the question
we're looking at is well can we actually
do this with natural language like to
say in this in this case push the thing
stapler forward uh it's much easier for
humans to provide and uh can flexibly
represent many tasks
it's a little more concretely kind of
this work we're trying to learn a
language condition Vision motor
manipulation skills on robots uh from
offline robot data and crowdsourced
annotation and uh critically we want to
learn from you know potentially highly
sub-optimal uh offline data that's not
expert data uh and so this might be for
example data from some agents that is
exploring autonomously or maybe reusing
the replay buffer of a previously
trained RL agent
and then we want to have crowdsource
sanitation test you know what tasks if
any are happening in this data set
and the kind of key idea in our work is
that you know we can't necessarily treat
the actions in this data as optimal uh
but what we do know is even if the agent
took a some sub-optimal trajectory going
from the beginning to the end of an
episode is going to complete you know
whatever instruction uh the human
annotated it with and uh we can then use
this to learn a language condition
reward function that can be used for
offline reinforcement learning
um
so at a high level our approach is going
to look like we'll have some offline
data
um we're going to get a crowdsword uh
have annotators have uh annotate what is
happening in each episode so some
episodes it might be do nothing some
episodes it might be you know try to
insert the marker in the whole and we're
going to use this to to learn a language
condition reward function
um in the interest of time I won't go
over the details on the exact uh offline
are all method we use like in our case
we use a model based approach but kind
of the the key component here is really
in learning the reward function that you
can use kind of with whatever your
favorite uh offline RL algorithm is
and uh how do we actually learn it well
uh the reward function we train is
basically just a binary classifier of
instruction completion so it's going to
take an initial State a final State uh
and some instruction and it's going to
predict does transitioning from that
initial state to final State complete
that instruction
uh collecting positive examples for this
is straightforward because we have
episodes in our offline data and their
corresponding annotations that we can
treat as positives and you can actually
generate you know basically as many
negatives as you want by randomly uh
kind of combining episodes with
different instructions and taking
instructions from a different episode
and and put in that in place or
reversing the episode
um you basically get these negatives and
and this classifier is going to use
um a pre-trained language model and uh
we'll see the a bit more about this in
in a few extra in a few slides in the
experiments but basically using this
pre-trained language model enables some
generalization even when you have
limited grounded data of uh episodes and
their corresponding uh annotations
so I'll skip over the the kind of
control part for now uh and then and
move on to just some of the highlighting
the experiments uh in the first one
we're basically just looking at how does
this compare to uh using like goal
images or specification or imitation
learning uh and the key takeaways here
are that you know because the data we're
trying to learn from is really
suboptimal uh if you were trying to
imitate it or do language condition
imitation on this data that's going to
perform poorly uh whereas using our
method you can actually improve over the
behavior policy that uh collected the
data and it also outperforms that using
Google images as your task specification
because those are kind of prone to uh
over specifying the task
the next thing we look at is
generalization to unseen kind of
phrasings of your different uh
commands so for example we might
normally be evaluating on tasks like
close the drawer turn the faucet left
and we look at okay what if we swap out
the verb or noun or both uh with an
unseen uh with unseen one or we we
actually sent out a survey to the lab
and said you know phrase this
instruction in some creative way someone
says I turn the faucet left so you might
say spin the nozzle left and what we see
is that uh with our method we're
actually
pretty robust to these rephrasings uh
with like at most a 10 drop in
performance and using a pre-trained
language model is critical for this if
we don't use a pre-trained language
model performance across the board is
worse even on the scene instructions and
uh it performs the grades a lot more
when you're giving unseen uh
instructions so so the so the
pre-trained model is pretty important
for this
uh and then the last thing we looked at
was trying to actually use this on a
real robot so we took basically the
replay buffer of from a totally
different project
um which was just 3000 episodes of the
replay buffer trying to do various
skills on this desk uh this uh this
robot interacting on this desk uh
consisting of many accounts successful
and unsuccessful attempts and that we
would crowdsource annotations for this
and then use our method so this is sort
of the interface we gave to the uh
annotators where we'd say Okay describe
what the robot's doing uh as a command
and then you know if you're if you're
not sure right do nothing or you can't
tell right uh n a
and so we got a lot of kind of very
creative annotations uh from uh from
from the crowdsourced workers
um things like you know rub the drawer
handle hit the rack with the marker
um but have just despite how noisy they
were we're still able to learn to then
be able to specify the robot to do tasks
like open the left drawer open the right
drawer
um moving the stapler and reaching like
the markers or reaching the the cabinet
um
and also being robust again to sort of
what different ways of rephrasing the
tasks so instead of saying uh move the
stapler we could say push the small gray
stapler around on top of the desk and
again I would say largely due to the
pre-trained language model it's still
able to
um to complete these tasks uh so just to
sum up I think the key takeaways are
you know to have multi-affected or
useful multitask robot policies humans
need easy ways of specifying tasks like
natural language uh and then using our
method we can learn these language
condition policies from very sub-optimal
offline data uh and then lastly the
pre-trained language models are are
important to actually being able to
generalized on scene tasks and while we
do not we don't actually have an
experiment testing this uh I I suspect
that it's critical to being able to
handle the diversity and crowdsource
sanitations when you have uh and tears
giving you all sorts of funny ways of
phrasing what the robot is doing uh I
think without the pre-trained language
model it would probably be very
difficult to learn from that
uh and so yeah that's uh that's that's
it thanks
um are there any questions in the
interest of time I won't be asking a
question myself
um let's see if there's anybody
right I don't see any questions now if
you have any questions please just write
them in the chat and I think maybe
swaraji if you can stick around for
another five minutes or so that would be
great sure um thank you sir
so um yeah we talked about how we can
fine tune these large models and then
how we can apply large language models
to other domains such as robotics with
reinforcement learning or imitation
learning a few takeaways we can
transform the gradient updates that can
allow us to edit models sufficiently and
then we can also use large language
models to both generalization and we've
found a few we've seen a few examples in
robotics that show how we can generalize
two new text commands and how we can
potentially generalize through new
languages even
potentially doing new tasks and maybe
even more as Eric was saying there's a
potential that there's there's a lot of
potential in these large language models
how they can be used
so next we'll talk about how we can make
reinforced learning a better data sponge
so what I mean by this is that if we
look at large language models for
instance or any supervised learning
recipes right now they require a lot of
data and very expressive capable ones
that can digest all of that data so in
other words they're able to to absorb
large amounts of data they're really
good data sponge and lifetime response
is a perfect example of that where they
can just you know go over the entire
Wikipedia and take all of the data in
and as a result we get really good
generalization out of these models so we
can prompt a model that was a little
screen like that with something that's
pretty clear that it shouldn't have seen
before such as create an image of a
snail made out of Corkscrew and it
actually does a pretty good job doing
that
now if we compare it to rainforcement
learning in reinforcement learning when
we usually talk about data we we digest
it's usually something like this we just
have a half cheetah and that's the only
environment we train on and we evaluate
on the same environment
even if we expand on that and use
something like metal world that we
discussed before
um if we look at performance of this
meta of these multitasking Force
modeling algorithms that they don't seem
to work very well across many different
tasks with different reward functions
different difficulties of tests and so
on
so if you want to uh you know draw a
data sponge analogy for us our data
sponge is not very very absorbent for
reinforcement learning
so I think one kind of sort of really
interesting directions and interesting
words is how we can make
um this this data sponge for reinforced
learning much more absorbent so rather
than working maybe a better sample
complexity so how to use less data how
we could work on algorithms that can
utilize and digest more data need better
data sponge
and in that thing we'll have uh four
presentations and first we'll start with
how we can in the first place just scale
up data collection itself and to talk
about this we have with us Archie Sharma
who's a PhD student with Chelsea Finn as
well
um Archer please take it away
great
um hi everyone I'm your favorite dirshit
and I'm going to be talking about what I
do outside holding officers and making
assignments
um more specifically I'm gonna talk
about RL and as I think Carol already
said we need to make like get more data
um and I'm gonna talk about why RL is
not able to scale up data collection at
this point and I would suggest like this
this boils down to making RL more
autonomous
um the motivation begins with like uh
comparing with how humans learn and in
this specific case we are looking at
examples of how a human juggles balls
and how they're learning
and this is obviously a very difficult
task so the human needs to practice the
star several times but the important
point that I would like to emphasize
here is that
um
that the human doesn't need external
help while practicing this task so the
balls fall down they pick it up they
start again and they improve by
themselves and this is a very important
point because to me this is the core
standard of autonomous learning
now let's contrast this with how like
robots actually learn and again in this
in these specific examples the first
robot is trying to hit the puck into a
goal and in the second example the robot
is trying to open the door
um
so in this case whenever the robot needs
to practice again a human first needs to
intervene into the data collection and
then it needs to reset the environment
so that the robot can start practice
again I hope at this point it's very
clear that the way robot learning
proceeds is far from autonomous even
though RL is such a great Paradigm for
learning
um it still relies on humans fairly
heavily
now learning autonomously isn't just
about
um mimicking humans
this this leads to practical problems as
well as some of the previous results
um previous videos suggested so more
specifically
um let's look at how RL works uh it
starts off with the state s naught and
then RL relies on collecting
trajectories in the environment where
and it collects a sequence of Architects
sequence of actions and collects a
trajectory like this from s naught a
naught s One S one and reaches a state
sh
um
after a point we terminate this
trajectory we re-initialize the
environment at s naught Prime and it
collects a new trajectory in the
environment
now reinforcement learning obviously
relies on a lot of practicing in the
environment
and collecting a lot of trajectories
like this but the big question is who
takes the
environment from the state as such to S
naught Prime
and this might not seem immediately
obvious but based on the examples that
you've seen thus far this often ends up
being humans and this ends up being a
major problem because you're almost
always reliant on humans being there for
the robots to continue learning
now assuming like you buy this premise
we decided wait we should if we we
should first look at like I mean it's
it's very easy to ask the question that
um
what if we just run our algorithms for
longer without resetting the environment
and this is kind of the question we
investigated as well before if we just
take our basic algorithms and just run
them longer
so we started with giving research every
thousand steps and we increased this to
200 000 steps and as you can see the
performance depreciates quite a lot um
which kind of suggests that the
algorithms that we have right now are
not exactly capable of operating
autonomously and they're very heavily
reliant on humans
so motivated by this we decided that we
should maybe change the problem itself
we should realize the constraint that
humans are not there to intervene for
the robots to continue learning and
and
so I'll skip a few details here but the
broad goal here is that the robot should
continue interacting and learning with
the environment and it's initialized at
environment once in the beginning but
after that the interaction continues for
posterity in formal terms this will
continue for an infinite Horizon but
there wouldn't be any research to like
generate new trajectories in the
environment and there are a few metrics
that we can optimize for
um but broadly you want to learn good
behaviors that robots would want to like
execute or be used for and this is what
we want to learn autonomously
all right
um now this is a really hard problem and
the way we do reinforcement learning
clearly is not sufficient for it so this
motivated us to create a nice Benchmark
where we have a diverse collection of
tasks which are representative of
realistic scenarios and we wanted to
like encourage the community to come up
with algorithms that can actually learn
without humans because that would enable
us to a run robots for longer collect a
lot more data and I would point out like
um a surprising result
um towards the end as well and some of
the tasks we consider are manipulation
related tasks we have a multitask
kitchen environment as well where you
have a diverse set of tasks as well we
have Locomotion and you have some like
higher dimensional textures and
manipulation tasks as well and we
strongly want the community to
participate in like improving the
algorithms and developing better
um
better ways to scale up data collection
and do RL in general
um unfortunately I do not have the time
to go into the details of how to build
these algorithms so I'm going to drop
some references here
um and always feel free to reach out to
me
but one thing I do want to like point
out to like keep the excitement is that
um
when agents learn autonomously
it naturally leads to robustness as you
saw in the example of how human is
learning they learn to correct their own
mistakes and this is a big part of
reinforcement learning but learning
autonomously encourages robustness in
even more and this is really desirable
for practical robot learning or
practical embodied agents and to explain
quickly explain the bar graph here the
Oracle is the policy that learns with
resets and we see a much larger drop in
performance from the gray bar to the
green bar when the conditions are
trained on changes whereas the fbrl and
VAP are are two different autonomous
algorithms and basically have no drop in
performance when the especially vapr
doesn't have a drop in performance when
the initial conditions of the
environment changes which suggests that
if you learn autonomously you would end
up learning robustly as well
so yeah that's my talk and feel free to
reach out to me on Ed or whatever so
yeah
thanks
thank you so much
um in the interest of time I will ask
people to ask questions in the chat
um for now actually we have one quick
question let's do it
I am sorry so good question is it um
still considered uh Thomas Learning if
you have a secondary robot residency on
an environment for you uh I noticed that
in like one of your examples video
examples uh door was opening and closing
and the human had to close door couldn't
that have easily been a song by having a
circle
um that's exactly one of the tasks we
have in the Benchmark and how you should
do it because the same robot can
actually learn how to open and close the
door right it doesn't need to be done by
the human
so if the robot like there are ways to
script these things as well so but the
idea is that we don't want to like spend
a lot of time with us doing the effort
but we want robots to learn without us
expending the effort so this is exactly
one of the tasks we have in the
Benchmark as well
thank you
thank you thanks archit and uh yeah if
you have more questions please ask the
channel
um all right so we talked a little bit
about how we can scale up data
collection let's now talk a little bit
about how we can use broader data
sources how we can actually make
reinforce modeling a better data sponge
so uh next up we have any Chan with us
with a PhD student with Charles Ethan
who will tell us a little bit about how
we can use other data sources as well
any take it away
great yeah so as Carol mentioned
um I hi everyone my name is Annie Chen
and I'm a PhD student working with
Chelsea
um and I'll be sharing a little bit from
a recent work on learning generalization
learning generalizable robotic reward
functions
um from in the wild human videos
and yeah this is a joint work with
stretchner and uh Chelsea
so we're motivated by the overarching
goal of a general purpose robot that's
capable of completing
um a wide range of tasks across many
different environments
um so towards this goal an agent must be
able to acquire some Metric of task
success or reward signal and this is
necessary for like reinforcement
learning planning um knowing when to ask
for help so here we're focused on
learning reward functions which allow a
robot to determine its own proficiency
at a specified task
um we're particularly interested in how
um in reward functions that can
generalize across varying environments
and tasks because otherwise we can't
hope for our agents to be able to use
them to learn general purpose policies
um so a promising path towards this goal
is to leverage large and diverse data
sets which we've seen have been
important in achieving broader
generalization capabilities in computer
vision and NLP
um however collecting large amounts of
diverse interaction data on real robots
can be pretty challenging and time
consuming
um so alternatively in the wild videos
of humans
um is this huge source of very diverse
data that already exists
um and so if we can teach robots using
this sort of data we can greatly
increase the diversity of the data that
our agents can learn from without
um much additional overhead
however
um learning from this sort of data is
very challenging for a number of reasons
um so first there exists a large visual
domain shift in the observation space
um second there's no clear mapping
between a human's action space and a
robot and lastly in the wild human
videos May often be low quality and
noisy
so how do we leverage this data for a
reward function
um the key idea to our approach which we
call domain agnostic video discriminator
or DVD is to train a discriminator that
looks at two videos and outputs whether
they're completing the same task or not
so we train the discriminator to predict
one if two videos are doing the same
task and zero if they are completing
different tasks we can then use this
discriminator in conjunction with any
human video demonstration as a rewards
function to solve the task that's
specified by that video
um
so unfortunately I think I'm gonna have
to skip the specifics of that for time
um but what this actually looks like is
given a human video demonstration for
closing a drawer
our method enables the agent to close
the door in these unseen test
environments
and here's another example with turning
a faucet to the right so even though as
you can see there's a large visual
domain shift between the given video and
the simulation environments
um DVD allows the agent to complete the
task in these unseen environments
the important takeaway is that training
using human videos shown in the purple
and red bars improves environment
generalization significantly compared to
only using robot data which is um shown
in the green bars
and here we also find that DVD works on
a real robot so uh the first video here
is the agent closing the door but
without having ever seen this toy
kitchen set before doing training
um and the second video which is pushing
the tissue box to the left is without
having seen any examples of this task of
pushing things to the left during
training
and so in summary DVD is a simple and
scalable approach to task specification
that can Leverage The diversity of in
these in the wild human videos
um to generalize some new environments
and tasks uh so the hope is that DVD
inspires future work in um applying
broad data sets for more robust
generalization capabilities
and there's a lot of really exciting
directions for future work along this
line so first our method focuses only on
learning reward functions that
generalize and doesn't actually learn a
generalizable policy directly uh also so
far we've only tested DVD on course
tests that don't require fine-grained
manipulation
um and lastly the reward is
non-markovian so uh but but it'd be
interesting to explore using the reward
um to learn model free policies with
memory
um and that's all I have so thank you
for listening and feel free to reach out
if you're curious to learn more about
this
thank you Amy thank you for the great
presentation and it's really cool to see
um having some works that apply uh data
that goes beyond just robotic data
um pretty cool
um the interest of time I'll ask
um students to ask questions in the chat
and we'll move to our next speaker who
is um Igor morta who's a research
scientist at the Google brain as well
and uh he will tell us a little bit more
about how we can actually simplify
during course learning formulation and
maybe use some of the ideas that we know
from large language models and
supervised learning
um to do reinforcement learning better
reinforced learning a little bit simpler
take it away here
yeah yeah thank you thank you
um so yes Carol was uh saying I will be
talking about treating reinforcement
learning as sequence modeling and by
sequence modeling colloquially I mean
combining say Transformer based
architectures with large-scale
pre-training and I believe Colin a few
weeks back already talked quite a bit
about uh about about such models so we
are seeing a lot of research compute and
infrastructure investment into this and
so it's worth asking how can we uh as
practitioners and Ai and Robotics get
the most out of this investment
um and so what we've tried to do is to
frame the problem of making decisions
which would normally associate with
reinforcement learning uh as a sequence
modeling problem and by that I mean not
just using say Transformer networks to
model your policy or value functions but
actually replace uh reinforcement
learning algorithms involving a lot of
moving pieces such as recursive
development updates choices of discounts
uh factors and so on replace all of that
complexity with just a single sequence
modeling objective
so this is a very drastic problem
reduction
but I think it's worth asking uh how far
can in just such a reduction take us and
this is the hypothesis that we try to
explore in the recent decision
Transformer paper with colleagues at UC
Berkeley
and so what we're going to be playing
around with here is actually just the
sequences the nature of the sequences
that we feed into these models uh the
choice that we've explored in the work
is actually sequences of returns
followed by States followed by actions
so these triples uh just repeated all
over for across different time steps and
by returns here I mean actually the sum
of all the future rewards so what this
in essence can actually do is it can
incorporate some hindsight information
you have about the outcomes of this
episode earlier on into the sequence
uh which ends up being very useful as
we'll see so we take this these tokens
of return States and actions uh feed
them into a causal Transformer model uh
such as for example what gbt models use
and we ask it to predict uh sequences of
actions
and at a deployment time we just Auto
regressively predict these action
sequences conditioned on some Target
return
or maybe more broadly some some notion
of optimality so for example we may ask
uh that we've seen you know there's some
Target score in a game that we know that
we can get to and we just and we've seen
that some demonstration data this is in
the offline RL setting was was able to
achieve it so we put that as Target and
this idea actually goes back has really
interesting Deep Roots uh in in optimal
control and then in prints
hello land so uh after doing all of this
uh the results are actually very
promising in the offline RL regime where
we're seeing we've tested it on discrete
control uh benchmarks such as a number
of Atari games continuous control like
the opening a gym environment
and uh these these um somewhat
unorthodox uh key to their environment
uh from from deepmind which basically is
uh really targeting long-term credit
assignment where I can only at the end
of the episode open the door and get a
reward uh if I have picked up the key
much much earlier on in the episode so
you really have to do the right thing in
the beginning so uh and we're seeing
that these models actually do in cases
significantly better than behavioral
cloning and in some cases kind of like
about the same or sometimes better
sometimes worse than temper and
difference learning approaches uh to
offline RL and there's actually some
some interesting things where when these
key to Door environments they they
attend to various very significant
actions like the the attention weights
in these models
I tend to significant events in the past
so I think I'll skip some of the
investigations
but the idea here is not to try to
introduce new algorithms or models but
it's really careful analysis and problem
reduction to actually Whittle down the
space of possible methods and strike for
Simplicity and the ways to be build on
our community's efforts more effectively
so these are the links to the paper and
the code if you're interested and I
think that's it for me
thank you so much
uh thanks for the great talk
um I'll also ask students to ask
questions from the chat in the interest
of time
um and next we have with us any chair
who will talk to us a little bit about
how we can apply reinforcement learning
to lifelong settings where we can extend
the the the pure 11 experiment or where
we can extend the lifetime of RL Beyond
a single experiment
um any is a PhD student with Chelsea
Finn
um Annie please take it away
uh so I I'm Annie and today I'll be
talking about some of our recent work on
lifelong robot learning
so some of the current ways to learn
multiple tasks are to learn each one
from scratch or to learn them together
under the multitask learning framework
and in standard multitask learning the
agent needs to collect data in each new
task uh sorry it needs to collect data
in each new task around Robin style but
this form of data collection isn't very
practical for a lot of real robot setups
and so
um for example if you consider this uh
these two tasks repeatedly switching
between those block insertion and this
bottle capping setup isn't very
realistic and what would be more natural
instead are robots that can learn uh
tasks and sequence and that's just the
lifelong learning problem so a lot of
the work in lifelong learning has been
concerned with catastrophic forgetting
which evaluates how well an agent that's
given a finite amount of memory and
parameters can perform on previously
solved tasks and in this setup we're
kind of concerned about a different
aspects of Life online which is for
transfer specifically we allow the agent
to retain all of its previous
experiences which isn't unreasonable if
we consider the cost of storing data
compared to the cost of collecting
significantly more data and so we also
simplify the problem a bit by assuming
that the state and action spaces are
shared between
inside the vary across the different
tasks and the agent in our setup also
only advances to the next task once it
finishes learning the current one
um so on the slide we outline our
solution to this problem which basically
alternates between an offline
pre-training phase and an online
Improvement phase for every new task
that comes in and during the offline
phase we are essentially restoring the
replay buffers from the earlier tasks
and pre-training the Agents on this data
then during the online phase we will
improve the agent's policy with data
that's collected online and instead of
just throwing away the prior experiences
at this point we can actually try to
reuse them
um but to account for like the
differences in the data distribution uh
we re-weigh the samples based on How
likely they are uh under the current
task versus an earlier one and this
ratio can be decomposed into these two
highlight terms here the first term
basically says given a transition How
likely is this sample from the current
task versus a previous one and we can
estimate this ratio with a binary
classifier that's trained on the
Transitions and we also transform this
ratio by thresholding it so we're
essentially filtering out the irrelevant
samples and we don't and basically we
don't have to actively use all the
samples in the data set
um and the second term that's underlined
in yellow can be estimated with the size
of the data sets and what this term is
basically saying is we're going to
decrease the weight of Prior samples as
we collect more new samples in the
current test
so next we actually wanted to leverage
the prior data even more specifically
for exploration
um essentially the intuition here is uh
that prior experience on related tasks
can inform the agent to which states to
explore in future ones for example a
robot that's doing tabletop manipulation
generally needs to move its arm towards
objects and we build in this heuristic
by appointing samples with states that
were more likely in the earlier tests
than the current ones and by doing so
the agent is incentivized to business on
more if they if they're useful
uh and then to evaluate our approach we
designed
um a family of key insertion tasks where
we vary the placement of the box as well
as whether they're placed flat or
vertically and we also varied the size
and the orientation of the key
um and for comparison we looked at the
part at a few prior approaches that
transfer learned weights like
Progressive networks and continuous
fine-tuning we also looked at approaches
that transfer prior data like this
method called dark and standard off
policy RL and overall our method
achieves the highest success rate
across the
um across three different task sequences
and it even does better than if we were
to learn each task from scratch
and then finally we evaluated
um our algorithm on a Franco robot on a
sequence of tasks that includes setups
like bottle capping and block insertion
and to summarize our method gets with uh
goal Which is less than half compared to
learning from scratch
yeah that's it
um here's I guess there's no time for
questions but feel free to contact me
yeah thank you so much Amy
um yeah we'll have questions on the
chats but if you could stick around a
little bit and that would be great
um thank you it's really cool to see
that we can go beyond kind of uh
removing all the or running collecting
data only for one paper and then
navigating back to this ever again
um very cool work thank you
um and yes I'll ask the students to ask
the questions over chat in the interest
of time
um and
I will switch over to prison thing
all right so we talked a little bit
about how we can um scale up data
collection how we can utilize broad
offline data sources including
non-rebonic data sources and then how we
can change the algorithms reinforcement
learning algorithms to look more like
supervised learning algorithms so that
they can utilize more data and then
um at the end any also told us a little
bit how we can apply reinforce learning
to lifelong settings
so
um there are a few takeaways that we
could draw from this
um we can scale up data collection by
eliminating resets and it's important
also to keep in mind that the Archer
pointed out in the um in the chat that
uh actually by making reinforcement
learning more autonomous unless there's
many more advantages than just scaling a
data collection and then there are
multiple ways to broaden data sources by
for instance incorporating in robotic
data such as human videos in the wild or
casting reinforcement learning into a
simple problem formulation
and then we can also extend
reinforcement learning to lifelong
settings by retaining experiences
all right so um in the remaining or we
don't have that much time so I wanted to
briefly tell you uh the remaining two
minutes let's say I wanted to briefly
tell you about some other open
challenges that we haven't previously
covered
um and there is a few although we
covered a lot of ground utilization
where we assume that our meta test
distribution meta training distributions
are the same and it's very often not the
case so we also need to be able to
generalize to out of distribution tasks
which is often the case with long tail
distributions and I'll skip the the
details on that
um we also need to look a little bit
more into multi-modality so how can we
learn prior from multiple modalities of
data so far we've mostly look at
problems where the predominant modality
was Vision there was many other
modalities that um you know such as
touch for instance that often are sound
that often have some
additional complementary forms of
information that we should be looking at
as well and then there are questions
regarding the algorithm and model
selection so answering questions such as
when will we know whether multitask or
meta learning is going to help or how to
select the best model based on the the
algorithm that we run
then there's more work to be done in
terms of benchmarks or although we are
getting a little bit better at this uh
we want to have benchmarks to have
sufficient breadth that challenge
current algorithms to find common
structure and then also benchmarks that
are realistic so that they can reflect
real world problems that we actually
care about and we've seen some examples
of that throughout the course but I
think uh there is more to be to be done
there and then there's some work to be
done on improving the core algorithms
themselves
um so I think the theory for most of
these methods is actually lagging behind
quite a bit
um so we need some additional work to
develop a theoretical understanding of
the performance of these algorithms we
can also look a little bit more into
multi-step problems or lifelong learning
problems we're performing tasking
sequence present challenges and as we've
seen in the previous lecture on Monday
um performing lifelong learning is
actually uh quite can be quite difficult
and very often
um it's understood in many different
ways so I think we could make a lot of
progress here
and then there's probably many more
challenges that you discovered in your
homework and in the in the final project
and since this is the the last lecture I
wanted to briefly go back to the bigger
picture
so at the beginning of the course we
talked about how machines are pretty
good Specialists they can solve things
such as Atari games or playing go or
even doing helicopter acrobatics
but they're pretty good in these narrow
domains
however when we when we look at humans
um we are pretty good what I would call
General less and what I mean by
generalists is that we can we have this
ability to learn many different skills
build on prior knowledge to adapt to new
environments and have some sort of
Common Sense
the the ml systems that I showed
previously on the other hand do not so
there are Specialists that try to master
a single task starting from scratch
disregarding a greater understanding of
how the world works
and in this class we took a step towards
building machines that are generalists
um there's a lot of topics that we
covered that go in that direction things
such as how to learn multiple tasks so
multitask learning how to leverage prior
experience when learning new things for
instance with meta learning how to solve
sequential decision problems with RL has
an alarm general purpose models with
model-based reinforcement learning how
to prepare for tasks before we even know
what they are it just would be that when
skill Discovery how to perform tasks in
sequence with hierarchy color Rail and
how to learn continuously
I think a lot of these things cover we
covered a number of things that can
bring us closer closer to this goal of
building generalist learning systems but
there's always a question you know
what's what's what else What's missing
and uh I think that now you should be
well equipped with uh with the tools
that you get to know in this class to
um to figure it out
thank you so much for being such an
engaging group there's a lot of fun
teaching this this quarter to to all of
you thank you also from the entire core
stuff from our first coordinator all the
Tas Chelsea myself
um thank you we'll see you